remakes and remasters aren't always my
favorite thing given there's the concern
that it's taking time away from
developers making new games that said
this certainly old games where it's
lovely to see them get a new lick of
paint here are four of those such games
that we can expect this year gamers were
a little burned by the fact that Final
Fantasy 7 / ps4 announced during the
PlayStation experience wasn't a noob
remaster but rather a port of the PC
version nonetheless there is a future
where you can play one of the best Final
Fantasy games on your ps4 so it's not
all bad the graphics have been upscaled
from their original 1997 resolution but
it's still largely blocky polygons
galore if you can put up with that and
you still have a truckload of nostalgic
love for the JRPG it could be worth
picking up the port from the PC version
also accumulates all the fixes from over
the years and features a character
booster which drastically boosts the
skill of a party on a save file so the
player can experience the story and not
need to grind for levels take this entry
with a grain of salt but since gamers
haven't been waiting for some kind of
Final Fantasy 7 remaster since the
possibility was first teased in 2005
this is at least a start speaking of the
best entries in long-running series
another game that came out in the late
90s is getting the remastered treatment
this month with Heroes of Might and
Magic 3 HD although it's nowhere near as
much of an upgrade as Ubisoft tried to
convince us it was since you wouldn't
really define the retouched up character
sprites as HD it's still a step up with
the game support for modern resolutions
there's also the addition of a
multiplayer Lobby compatible with steam
works to make playing online a whole lot
easier
unfortunately the excellent expansions
aren't included as a result of lost
source code the latest entry Heroes of
Might and Magic 6 might be detailed and
colorful but Heroes 3 had the best
strategy and town building elements of
this series which they've had trouble
topping ever since
this month isn't short of great
remasters since we're also hours away
from getting our hands on the new and
improved grim fandago the critically
acclaimed 1998 game from Tim Schafer is
considered a classic in the history of
adventure games but as is the case with
most 90s games getting it running on
modern machines is no small task and the
game's clunky Resident Evil style tank
controls were never a popular feature as
a result Double Fine has taken on the
task of producing a remaster for the ps4
Vita PC Mac and Linux platforms and
they're determined to do it right they
got in contact with players who had
written unofficial patches in some cases
requesting their code to integrate into
the remaster Similac who was also
involved they relied on uncovering 130
discs worth of original game assets
LucasArts had in their archives so they
didn't have to work with compressed art
thanks to that the game is set to
feature high res textures and character
models real-time lighting and the
ability to switch between the original
and the remastered graphics there's an
optional new control scheme and a
developer's commentary track for the
hardcore fans and the remake of remaster
I'm most excited for this year is the
Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask 3d if like
me you find yourself with the childhood
around the 90s and happened to have a
3ds this wonderfully moody entry into
the Legend of Zelda series offers a
delightfully dark world to explore like
al Carina of time 3d majora's mask 3d
will take advantage of the 3d s's
touchscreen controls gyroscope and
obviously 3d visuals as well as
incorporating better textures and
lighting the gameplay is also going to
be quote smoother according to creator
Aegean Numa and there will be changes
like altered boss battles and the
addition of fishing fans of the series
spent four years campaigning for this
remake ever since Ocarina of Time 3d was
released back in 2011 are you a fan of
remakes let me know which one of these
titles you're keen to play this year
a whole other game you want to get your
hands on I will see you next week